[Music]
so hi
my name is harvey lieberman and i'm here
today to tell you
a little bit about the our in pharma
organization
who we are what we do and how you can
get involved
if you're interested so
r is ubiquitous within the
pharmaceutical industry
but until recently there hasn't really
been a group that works across multiple
pharma companies
to provide a space for users to interact
in 2017 a group of our users from
several pharma companies
got together with other organizations
interested in this space
such as the fda and harvard to form a
group
and that's how our farmer was born
our farmers are an art consortium
isc working group it's organized by a
group of volunteers
from multiple organizations and some of
the companies involved in setting up
the iron pharma conference are listed on
this slide
now the goal of our pharma has been to
host
a scientifically and industry
oriented conference focused on the use
of art in the development of
pharmaceuticals
conference covers topics such as
genomics drug discovery
pkpd clinical trials regulatory
compliance and validation
as well as more general topics such as
reproducible research
and devops the focus is on the use of
our as a primary but not necessarily
exclusive tool
in the drug development process
we also hold workshops at the conference
but since the the primary focus is for
our practitioners
the workshops are really aimed at those
who already competent in
our anyone's welcome to present a
workshop and we're lucky to have some
really amazing presenters as you'll see
on some of the latest slides
now there are plenty of data science
conferences
workshops and and even organizations so
what makes us
different well for one we're
run by farmer for farmer we
concentrate on r which is not to say we
don't have contributing talks that
include
python sas or even julia but just that r
is the main focus
the rm pharma conference that we've held
the past
three years has been uh free
any cost has been assumed by an advisory
group
which is generally made up of pharma
companies willing to support the
cross fertilization that occurs when you
put a
bunch of curious programmers together in
a similar vein
we we have no sponsors and nor do we
allow sponsorship at the
the conference or any events because we
believe that
community-led effort works best when
there's no outside influence
we're also focused on diversity
and have goals on providing travel
grants to those who need assistance in
attending the meetings
so why am i here today well
i hope you're you'll understand that the
arthomer is a very open organization
made up of volunteers
we'd welcome anyone wishing to get
involved from presenting a meeting
to reaching out to the community with a
question and more on how you can get
involved in 2021 a little later
but first i'd like to share some
information on how we've evolved since
2018
our farmer holds a conference each year
the first was held in 2018 at harvard
and if you're unable to attend many of
the presentations
are available on the iron pharma website
the links on this slide
and i invite you to peruse them we had
around 150 attendees which was limited
by the
size of the venue and it ran over two
days
we're lucky to have some really amazing
keynotes that are listed here
there are a number of amazing general
presentations
that range from rna sequencing to
how to convert statisticians to data
scientists
um to using our energy xp environment
one thing that was clear from 2018
was that shiny was the main focus
of most presenters work
in 2019 we repeated the conference this
time expanding to longer workshops
each half a day once again the
conference was held at harvard
with a mixture of keynotes and general
presentations for around 150 attendees
um i'd really like to highlight the
workshops here so we reached out to a
number of
workshop presenters all of whom agreed
to put together a half-day workshop
at no cost and all the workshop
materials
and many of the presentations are
available through the iron farmer
website what was interesting in 2019
there was still a focus on shiny but
there was a huge focus on
reproducibility
so like many other groups in 2020 early
on we decided to switch to a fully
virtual conference
this provided few benefits over a
historical
in-person meeting first we could
reach more attendees and we received
over 500 registrations from 26 countries
we were expecting around 300 and
initially had prepared for
for up to but as soon as it opened it
was clear
that we were gonna hit a thousand plus
um and the
the graph on the the right is actually
really interesting it it shows
the registration this was registration
without
advertising so just through word of
mouth it's amazing how quickly
we had registration secondly we could
attract more presenters because people
didn't have to travel
there were more people willing to
present in fact we had over 200
proposals for presentations
conference was held over three days each
four hours long running in the morning
for those on the west coast of the us
and the evenings in europe
so i also want to highlight the
workshops that were held
for the 2020 conference because of the
virtual nature
we could organize a little bit
differently and stretched out over
multiple days
we ran a total of 11 workshops through
the week before the conference
each three to four hours long with some
incredible presenters who put a lot of
time and effort into building them
and all the environments were
pre-configured
under our studio cloud so it was very
easy for people to come
in use the materials and access them
afterwards
once again these were all put on by the
presenters at no charge
and once again the conference is is free
anyway
so it was a really amazing piece of work
our farmer meeting for 2021 is almost
certainly going to be a fully virtual
event
and thinking about the trends we've seen
over the past three years
i was definitely growing within the
pharma and biotech industries
at quite a rate um we now have more
mature infrastructures in place
and there's definitely a move towards
more submissions using r
in addition there's greater work in
combining languages such as r and python
and r and sas
i want to switch gear just a little bit
and talk about something new
we'll be launching a learning and
development platform this year
called learn rmpharma.com and the goal
of this is to help pharma professionals
develop the skills needed
in the drug development space the iron
pharma group will be
helping community members put on
workshops lectures
teaching labs in cloud environments with
the aim of building practical r skills
in in a friendly environment
a very high level what we're hoping to
do is to put together a monthly write-up
on a topic
and then follow it by a lecture or
workshop even a workflow
maybe a community discussion this is one
way that you the pharma community can
contribute
if you'd like to lead a discretion group
teacher lab please get in touch with us
contact details will be on the final
slide and keep an eye out for learnrm
pharmacom
i will announce more through a twitter
feed and the
uh rm pharma website
the first iron pharma conference that we
held three years ago was dominated by
shiny apps
we can see how shiny can play a role in
modernizing
the drug submission process but it's
fraught with challenges
these can be related to technology
regulatory agencies training and
validation
qualification and even people and
culture
plus others in 2021
our farmer wants to tackle shiny for
submissions
as part of learnrmpharma.com
i'm pharma is all about the community
helping the community
this year we're looking to launch the
learnarmfarmer.com
i i spoke about so if you have an idea
for a write-up
followed by a lecture workshop
discussion please reach out through the
website
email or twitter and we can help you
find
like-minded people provide logistics
some examples might be
combining r in python or building
a validation framework shiny for
submissions will be part of this too
finally a huge thank you to all of the
presenters and workshop hosts over the
past three years
putting so much effort along with the
advisory groups and harvard
who have supported the conferences that
we've held and
i thank you for your attention
you